Willam H my pleasure to introduce him he
was the inaugural chair for the
Department from 2003 to
2022 and he is well known for both
Education and Research and so we were
pleased to have him give us a talk today
on artificial
intelligence and he served as the
Director of our graduate program which
is the oldest and largest in the field
and some of you may know that our alumni
have gone on to create their own
programs a testament to and his program
so we we thank bill for his incredible
work there he's also an accomplished
researcher his main efforts are in the
area of information retrieval also known
as searching applied to biom Medicine
he's offered authored over 200 papers
and abstracts and you some of you may
know about his book information
retrieval a biomedical and health
perspective fourth edition came out in
2020 his current work focuses on
applications of search techniques to
electronic health record data death
aiming to improve patient cohort
Discovery and amp amplication of signals
of rare diseases welcome Bill thank you
Pizza in the room so make sure Here sign
in and grab the pizza this is good we
can see how many people okay there's 19
people online um okay well um thank you
Karen for that kind introduction
although you all know me so I appreciate
you keeping it short so I can actually
devote more time to the talk um I um th
this talk is a um well in October I was
um invited uh to give a talk to the OSU
Educators collaborative which is a group
of um faculty who are interested in um
Innovation and related issues in
education um they wanted to hear about a
um so I think I was talking to V and and
I know some of you attended that talk
which was virtual um and V you said well
you know maybe you should should give it
here um but but actually as I Was
preparing for it the last week or two I
decided um that it probably wouldn't be
good to repeat it in fact one of the
challenges with AI is that you know it's
like every week you know there's a new
paper or something that comes out that
changes it um but you'll actually
noticed I made a subtle change to the
title I swapped out Health Professions
for informatics because I thought I
would focus more on informatics I think
that Health Professions education is
actually important to us in informatics
because we um are the people among
others who are educating um health
profession you know medical students
nursing students Etc on um uh
informatics and AI uh but but there's
also issues important informatics and
plus um I actually have a little um I
wouldn't call it data but a little
experience I can report because I
actually tried um and actually I guess
uh there's some people in this room that
that took my course um this fall to
actually do something with um AI to kind
of confront this issue so I I'll talk
about that as well and then hopefully
leave some time for comments and
discussion so um so my objective so it's
slightly different from the previous
talk but
I I'll kind of give the 40,000 foot
overview of of AI just kind of level set
people I'll try to go through that
quickly um then talk about some of the
key issues for AI and informatics
education and then also talk about
opportunities uh which I always uh like
to encourage uh students uh to do so so
this is a revision of the talk that I
gave earlier and and I'll try to leave
maybe 10 or 15 minutes for a
discussion um so you're always supposed
to give a Financial disclosure I I don't
have any stock or companies um and
actually I stole this from Jim simino
who use this at the Amia meeting but um
I don't know I do pay $20 a month to
open AI is that a conflict I'll let you
decide and then you can decide whether
you want to uh believe what I have to
say so okay Ju Just to um again get up
to the 40,000 foot level you all
probably know this um so you know AI
um I always like the definitions that
that talk about you know basically
information systems and algorithms
capable of Performing tasks associated
with human intelligence and there's all
kinds of different variations on that um
lately we've been grouping AI into two
broad categories uh predictive AI that
focus on things like diagnosis and and
treatment and things like that aiming to
predict some sort of output and that's
that's kind of the main work that's gone
on um until um literally about a year
ago although actually um people were
doing generative AI before chat GPT was
released um but but generative AI
generating new output um particularly
based on prompts not only text images
other things and of course a large part
of the success is due to machine
learning um which are computer programs
that learn without being explicitly
programmed and the most success some of
you know more about this than I do um
with um things like deep learning based
on many layer neural networks and so
forth um you know when you get up in the
Years you can start like reminiscing
about the days but but anyways I I
entered the field right at the very uh
tail end of the first era of AI and and
AI had a lot of hype back then you know
of course we didn't have social media
and everything else but there was hype
you know getting Congress to to support
research and AI
um the the um ethnic group that we were
worried about in the 1980s was the
Japanese um and um um you know so we
need to compete with Japan we can't lose
this battle you know it's the future da
da da U but anyways um the the first
year of AI um actually was was a big
part of the field and then it all came
to an end so there was the famous ladley
lusted paper that looked at um
uh that that aiming to model physician
reasoning U through combination of
symbolic logic so symbols representing
findings and diagnosis and treatments
and things like that and then
probabilities um Homer Warner the the
late uh Homer Warner uh was the first to
develop a mathematical model for a
disease in in this case congenital heart
disease um the real thrust of the effort
took part in the 60s and 70s um which
was alive then although very young not
not yet um working in the field but um
the expert systems that were basically
computer programs aiming to mimic expert
human expertise and there's a nice book
that was recently published and and by
the way I um I have a PDF of my
references and slides on my website I
will I will give you the link at the end
um but most of you know how to find my
website and um uh anyways and this led
to the rule-based systems so that's um
why
is this go on um the um uh and and in
fact Ted short left one of the founders
of our field his P PhD dissertation in
the late 60s early 70s he was an MD PhD
student at Stanford um developed the
first world-based expert systems and and
others followed on and then another
approach developed disease profiles and
scoring algorithms the famous internist
one uh system and also another one
called d explan
um but all this started to Peter out
right when I was a fellow just like some
of you um in the late 1980s I was an nlm
fellow and um uh you know basically
trying to build these huge knowledge
resources and then develop computer
programs to act on them um was difficult
to scale and to be sustainable um and
and actually in the early 1990s the
whole um we actually stopped talking
about AI um in fact some people that
kind of time period in the 90s and and
through the turn of the century the AI
winter and about the only piece of it
that remains is the clinical decision
support that we see in electronic health
records uh but most of the rest of it
has gone away and um um it clearly
trying to build the knowledge of
especially something as complex as
medicine is is actually something humans
can't do now there were people doing
machine learning back then um but um
there was no data um the there were the
computers of the day were you know less
powerful than uh you know like my Apple
watch our phones and so forth um but
then um so so AI kind of died in fact
one way to look at it is I almost got to
the point where I was gonna throw this
part of my introductory course which a
number of you in this room have taken
BMI 510 just out of the course because
you know AI wasn't a thing um I never
quite did though I always thought it
should stay and obviously I'm glad I did
and now it's a big part of the course
again but anyways so really what
happened um that in this second era of
AI is um the machine learning um massive
amounts of data available the internet
electronic health records all the
images and and of course more powerful
computers and and networks and um and
then the breakthroughs in in deep
learning and um Jeff Sir Jeffrey Hinton
who um um actually is is known in
medicine for saying about seven or eight
years ago though he has since recanted
his statement that there's no future in
fields like Radiology it's all going to
be done by AI he he he he has stepped
back from that but but he he developed
the algorithms that that um enabled um
um deep learning to classify images and
and that was the kind of first success
in this new era so being able to look at
the image of an eye and the inside of an
eye and diagnosed diabetes diabetic
retinopathy a chest x-ray pneumonia
tuberculosis pathology images cancer um
and skin lesions things like melanoma
and um AI algorithms as you all know are
are very good at that now um and um um
they perform you know with clean data
sets and and out not in the real world
but in kind of controlled conditions um
as well as human
experts um and it's not just limited to
Imaging so um predicting Adverse Events
in hospitals actually this is a big one
now generating clinical notes this
become a commercial thing um actually I
know Anessa is very involv in that um an
age-old problem in biology um predicting
protein folding from amino acid
sequences which could never be done um
but then um machine learning algorithms
can do it quite effectively um being
able to classify cancers sometimes
cancers of of unknown primary predicting
survival um predicting patient courses
um the last two ones I I think are
interesting um um basically um
reconstructing voice from uh functional
MRI images um and then also another
paper recently uh mapping chemicals that
are in the air to the odors that we as
humans perceive so I you know Ai and
machine learning are getting in
everywhere um another interesting thing
is that um AI can see things that we as
humans can't and um one of my favorite
people to follow is um Eric toppel and
he um
um has written a lot about this and and
there's all these references but um for
example looking at a picture of a retina
and Discerning age um biological sex um
race sex Aaron coiner one of our former
students um was able to do this it that
we can't see as humans you know we look
inside the eye with a philoscope and we
can't tell these things um same thing
with electrocardiograms um age
biological sex uh wrist ratification
kidney chronic kidney disease um um left
ventricular systolic dysfunction I see
came across a paper the other day um
Parkinson's disease there's something
that machine learning algorithms can um
process about an EKG that are not
perfectly predictive but highly
predictive Parkinson's disease same
thing for chest x-rays um race cardiac
function diabetes
um and even voice data some of us in
this room are involved in the bridge to
AI project on voice biomarkers and there
was a paper published recently that um
uh machine learning algorithms can
discern differences like for example
does someone have type two diabetes so
this I mean some of these are are
potentially important others raise
Pandora's Box issues like you know race
and and biological sex and things like
that um and then so so that's predictive
Ai and then there's generative AI um
which um November 30th 2022 I remember
the day um chat GPT became available um
and um most of you know how these um
large language models work they
basically take massive amounts of text
that is on the internet in books other
places um and um use Transformer models
that um basically build these models and
um they basically work by predicting the
next word in sequence and when you have
billions or trillions of words um you
can do that quite effectively and in
addition when you um look when you
measure the attention kind of the um
what the word's about um and um and then
these systems are fine-tuned with a
process called reinforcement Lear
learning from Human feedback although
there's also new uh methods that are
being developed um and then everything
revolves around prompting and I will
talk more about prompting it's a skill
that we all um need to have being able
to prompt AI
systems and um generative AI is is more
than chat GPT so for example um Bing the
search engine actually uses a version of
gp4 um Google you can sign up and you
can get Genera AI um that comes with
your Google search um chat GPT also can
be extended there's there's plugins um
for example scholar AI which um searches
PubMed it doesn't do it I don't think
really well um there's another system
that will generate PowerPoint
presentations from text which I also I
don't think it works that well but um
and then another one that summarizes
scientific papers and then you know for
those of us who work in information
retrieval the the new hot thing um is
something called retrieval augmented
generation one of the problems with uh
generative AI is that it hallucinates
sometimes it gives the wrong answer um
and um the idea behind retrieval
augmented generation is to basically do
a search an information retrieval search
um and actually use that in the prompt
and there there's not a lot of good
research results yet but but that's the
promise of that technique and then
another um thing that's happening is can
we use smaller language models also ones
that are more focused for example right
now the the general models work best for
medical tasks but in the future can we
train large language or even smaller
language models with medical records um
things like
that um so how well do these systems do
I um I call it the USMLE arms race um
because one of the first um one of the
first accomplishments was basically um
passing um well the there's there's
sample questions for you know medical
students when they go through training
they take step one in their second year
step two in their fourth year and then
as an intern step three um and uh
there's sample questions on the US mle
site in fact there's a data set that
that machine learning researchers use
and you can see how well the uh
performance has increased it was a big
deal um a year ago when um GPT 3.5 the
original GPT and chat GPT got 60% which
is around a passing grade um but now the
numbers are up to um
90% um there there was a paper published
by group of Microsoft research um and
using gp4 and also some very specific
kind of prompting and um um this I
assume this arms race will go on because
um Google system Med palom is is up
there um and um there will probably be
others that that come and and then it's
actually not only the medical licensing
exam it's actually all these board exams
including that some people in this room
will take someday the clinical
informatics board exam um GPT 3.5 gets a
score of about 60% that was a paper
published um by yakuma Crystal a few
months ago um I actually um well well
and then um other fields
Radiology um neurology um there's one
field that it hasn't um didn't achieve a
quote unquote passing grade which is
neonatology but they use GPT 3.5 I I
actually know Andrew beam the author so
I asked him he he a week ago and he said
oh yeah we have a paper under review we
got 90% with gp4 so gp4 is right now the
kind of the gold standard for most tasks
although um there will um you know these
are still relatively early days and I
I've encouraged yakuma Crystal to use
gp4 on the clinical informatics board
exam I'd be interested to see but it's
not just answering board exams questions
it's answering other kinds of medical
questions there's a ton of papers out
there I reference a few here um solving
clinical cases um with basically um chat
GPT although now most research is is
done using either gp4 or Google system
um and um oftentimes comparable too but
not necessarily better than the
experts and um um other things
communicating with uh patients um being
able to answer questions that get posted
in social media forums um being able to
generate letters actually um epic and
other systems now are starting to
implement this generating draft letters
that PHS can use there there was one
study um although I know there's some
dispute about it but but that that the
uh letters coming out of the generative
AI were rated as more empathetic than
what Physicians wrote um generating
Surgical consents and then actually
closing the loop with predictive AI um
classifying um chest x-ray findings
based on a combination of images and
reports using large generalized models
um and then also this latter one which
you know I think about these days as one
gets in the years of cardiovascular risk
but um predicting cardiovascular risk
from things like the framing ham
models um but there are some downsides
you're all probably uh familiar with
these um clear clearly one of the this
is the the fabrication some some call
hallucinations um there have been a
number of different studies looking at
at the references that get generated um
I actually did this myself in the very
early days I I published it in my blog I
probably should have tried to publish it
as paper but anyways other people did um
and um you know making up references or
or having errors within them um another
issue is that since these large language
models are based on the language that is
out there um
perpetuating um harmful race-based
medicine um this is always been an issue
with um when you apply machine learning
to the text of the world um also um
creating compelling disinformation and
and humans not being able to distinguish
um the information coming from um large
language
models um and then um these large
language models again reflecting the
content and the bias and and even
there's issues about intellectual
property um and in fact actually I I
realized I realized this just a few
weeks ago that I I've actually
contributed to the training of um of of
many of these large language models
because our server d. ohsu.edu is part
of the Colossal clean crawled Corpus
which is this large Corpus of of a
essentially a web crawl that is used in
for this kind of research um so um you
know maybe my intellectual property has
been stolen but um I'm okay with that um
I do put it out there um and then
there's the issue of of detecting um GPT
I'm going to talk about you know the
academic issues that's kind of the main
focus of this talk but um um the some of
them do well it it it also depends on
the type of um
material the the the type of question
that's being asked or or the type of
content coming out um one one
interesting side finding is that uh
non-native English writers are are more
likely to have their taex classified as
being AI generated which also raises
some issues of bias um and um and the
flip side of that of humans being able
to discern AI writing um are are not uh
able to do that
well and there are some issues with AI
in general um one is is that this was a
paper in anals of internal medicine um a
few months ago uh once we start
deploying these models and using them
we're we're changing the world because
these models are now part of the world
and so um how do we handle that um
another issue is our things like
automation bias so if you have um and
I'm not just talking about um generative
AI here but
Radiologists um uh being being biased
actually in either direction either um
relying too much on the AI
interpretation or or not enough um then
issues when you move it out to the real
world um um there um many of these
systems have there's been a lot of
projects using them in rural areas um
not only in the US but around the world
um but you get into challenges when you
of trying to collect decent um for
example retinal images um when you're
out in in as this paper reported in
rural Thailand or rural India probably
it would happen many places around the
us too um and then the issue of
reproducibility of these algorithms um
um these systems are are always changing
um these systems are developed by big
companies and so there's there's not a
lot of transparency that we as users can
see um and then you have you know again
this issue of data bias and then also
data leakage where you have instances
where some of the data in the test
collection in the test part of the data
set um are in the model um and and um
you know so usually the way you do these
models is you have a you have training
data to train the model then you set it
to work with the test data but if if
some of the training has taken place
with the test data then you're
potentially um biasing the model that
that's called Data leakage and there's a
nice paper that uh that talks about all
the different kinds of data leakage that
um can occur and how to look for it so
so will AI help or hinder healthc care
um probably many of you have seen me
throw the famous picture up of Dr McCoy
who um you know was um had a lot of
Technology at his disp osal but you know
was the empathetic physician taking care
of his patients um so um is that the
future we'll see or will it be more um
ominous well well one thing is that
despite of all the hype that there's
actually relatively modest real world
use of AI there there was a survey
published by the um mgma which
represents medical groups um and only
21% of medical groups reported that
they're using um and I suppose it
depends on how you define AI um but um
not not a whole lot of use in the real
world yet um and if you ask these groups
what their priorities are it's like yeah
they're concerned about AI but they're
much more concerned about EHR usability
patient Communications and billing um
over AI may maybe that'll change in the
future um then um there what about the
evidence base um there are um there have
been three now and I try to follow these
things closely systematic reviews of of
randomized control Trials of predictive
AI systems um and you can kind of
generalize from the results one is that
there are there's a pittance of clinical
trials compared to model papers so um
the each of these three systematic
reviews depending on how they included
and excluded things has about 40 to 80
randomized control trials in their
systematic review as opposed to if you
do a Medline a pub Med search on
predictive AI models you'll get
thousands of hits in fact you'll find
thousands of systematic reviews of um
model papers so so there's a lot of
model papers out there and there's a lot
fewer um studies in the real world um
and in all of these systematic reviews
they found concerns about risk of bias
um and not all the results were positive
some were positive some were negative so
um so a AI is not quite ready to replace
Physicians and Curtis langlotz who's a a
radiologist at Stanford another friend
of mine um uh has been quoted AI won't
replace Radiologists but Radiologists
who use AI will replace Radiologists who
don't and I always tell people plug in
your health profession there um and all
of this must be implemented in
responsible ways and our uh David door
had a really nice uh perspective in Jama
earlier this year um talking about
responsible use of of AI and he's
involved in the committee with the
National Academy of Medicine um so just
a few examples of what we need to do to
build the evidence base um well or or
some of the things we need to think
about so uh it's not a it's still a Hot
Topic but it's not as hot of a topic as
it was about 10 years ago when um the
CMS the funer for Medicare said um you
know how hospitals you need to reduce
the number of patients who get
readmitted and we're actually going to
penalize you so everyone and their
brother set off to develop algorithms
and it turns out you can actually
predict it very easily um who's likely
to be readmitted um but but you know
that's not the end of it you actually
have to show that you can take this data
and Implement some kind of intervention
and in fact there was a big randomized
control trial in Switzerland published
earlier this year
um they put this whole um infrastructure
around it and actually had no difference
in hospital readmissions and um Bob wer
who WR also writes a lot about AI noted
that just because we can predict
something does not mean we can
necessarily do something about it um
like likewise models for predicting um
uh development of chronic kidney disease
that's been another area there there's
also a kind of side issue with that is
the the use of race in those algorithms
but the the main issue is you know how
you know can you predict kidney disease
and then if you can predict it can you
do anything about it and so new models
have been developed a lot of the work
trying to get race out of the equation
but um in the process and these new
models are very accurate um but you know
people are raising the question well
okay um you know
um can't it if we have these models um
do do we know that they're going to do
anything because if we start looking at
early kidney disease we might subject
people to intervenous contrast in
imaging studies which of course is
detrimental to kidneys U patient anxiety
unnecessary testing and this editorial
that Acom accompanied this paper is um
what we really need are clinical trials
to validate use of the model and then
one more um th this has probably been
the most clinically studied area of AI
which is um detection of Pops you know
so um I I probably shouldn't keep
talking about age but you know when you
reach a certain age you know you have
that test where they look in your colon
and it turns out that the endoscopists
Miss pops especially small ones and you
know and you know the goal of
colonoscopy is to find those pops early
especially the ones that have the
potential to develop into the colon
cancer and and remove them well um
um it turns out that AI assistants are
actually very good at helping Point col
um colonoscopist to Pops that are out
there uh that are in there I should say
in the Colin um the the problem though
is that the ones they detect tend to be
the the non-cancerous ones and it's not
clear that those develop into cancerous
ones um and in fact there there was a
randomized control trial that that
basically compared um I can't remember
what the control group was um but the
intervention was the AI assistant saying
you know look here look here um and
there was um no difference in detection
of advanced coloral um
neoplasias and so um um there was a was
always an accompanying editorial that
said you know there's there's challenges
in implementing um AI in the real world
um which may impact the results but but
we must build the evidence space if
we're going to um uh detect it so let me
then shift gears to um informatics um
education and so the two main questions
I'm going to ask what what is the
optimal use of generative AI in learning
and kind of a a sub question um when
might its use be detrimental or
unethical and then what opportunities
are
there um does anyone under 30 know what
I'm holding in my
hand under under 30 is that maybe
there's no one in here who's under 30
how about under 40 yeah you guys
probably know what that
is anyways you know I I at I I was in
high school in the mid 1970s when this
shift was taking place I learned how to
use a slide R in my high school
chemistry class but by the time I got to
physics they're like okay you can use
calculators now and there was so much
debate I don't know if the generative AI
thing is the same but I was just
thinking about that but anyways I I keep
my uh slide rule as a prop okay now I
can take selfies with it um anyways so
but but this is an issue and and any of
us who teach and and all of us in this
room either teach or take courses um
there's a lot of things that can be done
in um the way we teach uh using
generative AA not only answering the
kinds of multiple choice questions that
I give but programming assignments um
you know chat GPT is very effective at
generating code um and um there's a lot
of angst in the educational World about
um not only the biomedical education
world but the world as a whole um one
person who I actually like to follow on
actually on Twitter and he also has a
substack um is Ethan mik he was one of
the first people to start you know
addressing this issue head on and um so
I'm going to talk a little bit about
what I've done and and then you know we
we'll throw it open for conversation um
at the end but um so we do now actually
have a generative AI policy from the
Provost um which wasn't widely
publicized but I learned about recently
pardon me where is it oh and I have the
URL to it um although it's on O2 so you
know you have to either be on VPN or I
don't know why it's not make a public
anyways and I as some of you know
developed one for my course and then I
um one of my colleagues at the amen
meeting said you know we need to play
offense on this you know we need to
actually engage the use of this so I
tried it um this term and um I I'll
report my quote unquote results it would
be a stretch to really call them results
but um oh and then this this was
published just I don't know about a week
or two ago um it it's they they a
thousand college students it's a website
so it you know it's it's not scientific
um but um but I am I'm sure they found a
thousand real students and asked them
but you know if you look at the numbers
um 56% of college students have used AI
tools to help complete assignments or
exams um 53% has had coursework that
requires it to be used um 79% have had
at least one instructor that discussed
the use and these students over half of
them um at least according to this
survey believe that um using these tools
to complete assignments or exams is
cheating or plagiarism um obviously if
the instructor allows it it's not
cheating or plagiarism but um and and
then my school has a policy and you see
here um that's
58% um and so mik um this is what
actually kind of motivated me um he
published this paper um called assigning
Ai and he talks about the different ways
that you can use Ai and the role that
students would play and the benefit and
the risk and and he clearly acknowledges
there there is risk um but he like many
instructors has started to incorporate
AI especially generative AI into his um
courses his
teaching um so
um uh I um actually there was an
incident this last term where there was
some concern that um you know actually
many people in this room Tak my course
um about uh you know using the
discussion forums on Sakai and the um
whether there were students who were um
using chat GPT to generate text for that
and um my my view on the discussion
forum is this really a place for people
to talk um and um I don't think it's a
good use but I had no policy about it so
actually I um I actually have to
attribute um Steve bedrick here uh who
who had also developed earlier a a
policy for his courses um that tend to
be more programming oriented and so um I
am using um his um ideas and and others
that I'd read online came up with this
policy and in particular for the
specific activities of the Court so for
the discussion forums I'm like you
please you really shouldn't be doing
this um for things like homework um uh
and the final exam I I tend to prefer
open book kinds of homeworks and exams
because I think it's more important for
people to apply the knowledge than to
memorize it um but obviously if you have
chat GPT at your disposal um that um you
know potentially undermines that
approach
um I'm not well I wasn't too worried
about chat GPT writing term papers but
um I'm more worried about that now not
not so much writing it beginning to end
but but people chunking things together
um and um encouraging people not and and
and telling students if if you have a
question about what you think is
appropriate you know talk to me or the
instructor um and um certainly we expect
um work to be students own original work
um so here is the um provos policy and
um if you get these slides you can just
click on the link and I'll show you how
to get the slides at the end um and um
the the provos policy is good um it it's
a little more General um and I think
probably for a lot of courses we're
going to need more specific um guidance
on what we think is appropriate or not
so what did I do I I thought okay well
let's let's address this henon so many
of you know um the the BMI 510 course
that many of you have taken um there's
another version of it called 10 by10
that's more of a continuing education
course and the assignment in that course
is shorter um but basically I said okay
um if students want to um try to use and
learn how to prompt um generative AI
let's do it so um so I set some
parameters I said so first you have to
choose at least three topics generally
in the term paper I I tell students that
um you know pick an area of informatics
you're interested in and go beyond what
we cover in the course and you will
hopefully learn from it um and um write
a good paper um so I thought for this I
said okay pick um at least three topics
that you have an interest in um or
questions Beyond what's in the course
you need to use at least two different
um generative AI systems I I
suggested uh perplexity AI as the second
one because that actually gives you
references and and that's what most
people ended up doing I didn't mean to
steer them in that way I said you know
there's also um generative AI embedded
in search engines um you should have at
least three iterations so the initial
prompt and two more um and then you
should analyze the output um with a page
or two of what did it get right are
there things it it got wrong are there
things it should have said but didn't um
and um and if the systems generate
references are those references real and
or are they um um
confabulated and and then if those are
references are they good ones are there
other ones that should have been there
um and and then in the 10x10 course it
was just a scaled back version they just
had to have one conversation
with the three iterations and the
analysis um so here's my results I
should actually put it in quotes because
I actually didn't actually get
IRB but anyways I'm talking very general
terms here so um so what well and and I
I gave students the option of doing this
or just the regular assignment so in the
10 by10 course they they write a two to
three page short paper um on a problem
that they want to use informatics to
solve six of the 21 students uh opted
for the um chat of for the generative AI
option um in and this actually surprised
me um in in in BMI 510 only three out of
15 chose it um and the rest wrote papers
very good papers um and that's fine I I
the goal was not to make them do this um
so how how do I assess the situation so
for the most part the students carried
out the assignment as I instructed them
um for 510 where they had to use a
second llm I most of them use perplexity
I that probably is because that's what I
gave as an example um I thought all of
their assessments of the output were
good they discussed um you know what
came out what um should have been um
what might have been there in addition
um one one student did a phenomenal job
you know like should have cited and and
there's like a I think there's like over
a page of references of you know things
that were important to this topic um and
then another student actually created
this nice table of like features or
attributes and evaluated them in um
comparing the two different language
models so um I'll probably continue this
but um uh it is just interesting so let
me close for a few minutes and then then
we'll we'll stop um the the the other
thing I just want to talk about is
another educational issue which I think
are our opportunities for informatic
students um the these are still the
early days you know thousands of model
papers um 40 randomized control trials
and there's still a lot that we need to
know about um um implementation
evaluation and risk so um and I I think
the
translational kind kind of uh framework
applies here so as you know in medical
schools we have basic science and
clinical science and basic science basic
scientists are across the street in the
labs doing experiments with tissue
cultures and mice and whatever um and um
that they identify the promising drugs
the promising tests and things like that
um but it doesn't stop there it needs to
actually cross the Street into the
hospital so that it's translated um with
real world patients um and then we need
to generate evidence as we tend to call
it on the clinical side that demonstrate
there's some kind of value to a patient
for their disease for their health or
for the Health Care System um and
actually um in my blog when the bridge
to AI project was first starting they
they were encouraging people to make
suggestions for Grand challenges and I
said this should be a grand
challenge um translational AI um and I
was actually asked to present at this
virtual meeting um but as those of you
who know brid du AI they chose a very
different path so I I didn't encourage
them um to to take up this although I I
think most people would agree that this
is important um and in fact um we're
starting to see now some studies that
involve users this was a a a paper that
came out of Microsoft research or no I'm
sorry came of Google um using their
large language models where they
actually um gave um real world real
clinicians Physicians um a case vignette
and asked them to generate a
differential diagnosis a list of
possibilities um interestingly enough
you see this graph in the lower left um
the large language model actually did
best um the clinician assisted by the
large language model did second best the
uh clinician that the control group was
basically they said to the clinicians
you can go search Google ofed um they
did um uh worse and clinicians who had
no assistance at all were down at the
bottom um they they were also very happy
to point out in the lower right that um
the Google um llm did better than gp4
for this task um and the the numbers
just just kind of reiterate what the
graphs show um this isn't a perfect
study but but I think it's a good
direction that uh we should be heading
um how do real world clinicians use this
stuff um and in fact again uh pulling my
uh age out of here maybe experience um
that if I look back at some of the
studies that I did uh um some of my
early research you know it's not a
probably not that big of a deal these
days but how well do clinicians use
search systems um back in the day when
not everyone you know had it on your
phone and whatever um and so we found
out some interesting things so one is
that the um differences um in things we
ask the users to do like could they
answer questions overwhelmed the metrics
that we look at the system things like
recall and precision how many relevant
articles things like that um we also
found that just because you're system
retrieves something that answers the
question right there in front of their
face on the screen doesn't mean that
they answer the question correctly and
and that there were some not
insignificant number of instances where
they do worse after they have the
intervention we we would have them
answer the question without anything and
then they could um look it up in I think
it was us well one of these was using a
medical textbook the other one Medline
and in some not insignificant number of
cases they went from correct to
incorrect answer so um just uh in
conclusion and then I will open it up uh
to you all um uh I I I do believe that
AI is going to profoundly impact
everything we do um despite the hype um
but right now the day-to-day impact is
small and and we need to figure out how
to implement these systems in real world
in the real world um both Educators and
students need to figure out how um uh
generative AI is is going to be used if
it if it keeps people from learning I'm
not one of those people that thinks you
know everything needs to be in your
brain but um people need to understand
things to be able to critically think
and so forth and um we don't want AI
tools to worsen that and then you know I
think there's a lot of opportunities for
um information atic students so I will
um uh open the floor to questions I will
uh before I do that though I just want
to mention that I I got interviewed by a
p on a podcast that was just published
yesterday um called health and
explainable AI um and um you can go
listen to that um I also wanted to let
people know that U my textbook which
some of you know about um is going to be
available for viewing on the library
website um not down Lo in but viewing
and I'll I'll publicize this but you
have to log in with your OSU credentials
um and then I'm also going to be on
another podcast it's some you know Kevin
Johnson um who uh um on on what life is
like after leadership anyway so I will
stop at that point and um answer any or
would like to hear comments and if I
have anything to add I will um I think
we we
see um can we see the chat here or or
may I don't know if
anyone's anyway someone's someone out
there is going to have to speak up okay
but let let me just open the floor I'd
be curious um any thoughts comments
about um uh what I've talked about yeah
go
ahead Jones hospitalist lots of
Education
dabling in charge of Competency Based
education portfolio for the school of
medicine you did a lot of student
assessment as well m one of the things
that most interests me in AI is um using
the language model for uh asynchronous
opportunities for student reps whether
it be clinical or other learning
experiences how large langage models can
help facilitate the problem we have an
education if you do written assessments
and provide some type of assessment
input uh you either have to pay a person
to sit around and read a lot of text
which becomes costly and non ruble
uh how we inter interject large Zone
models key to be able to evaluate the
text provide a reliable reproducible
score and syst on that information
yeah that's a great qu that's a great
research question we need to find an
informatic student to um um no yeah I I
mean I I have read a number of papers
talk about using um large language
models in like simulation you know of um
uh um generating cases things like that
um grading you know evaluating I think
is a little bit more challenging because
you know then what is the gold standard
there's another interesting finding that
um large language model systems when
they are asked to evaluate the output of
large language models tend to rate their
own model the highest so if you ask gp4
you know you give it different kinds of
text um it'll rank the stuff that came
out of G pt4 like likewise llama the
Google
system um that's a good question I I
don't know if anyone else has any
answers Steve reliable andu are not
adjectives that we use about large
language models from techical
standpoint and just Echo the reason they
do that is because when we ask an LM to
rate something or what it's actually
computationally doing is measuring
statistical likelihood um of the actual
words that are in the text box and so
that's why if it looks like output it
would have produced will give it a
higher score totally independent of any
kind of ontological or factual reality
of what the content is yeah um so it
seems hard to think about how like
that's part of why using it foress the
other the other using for assessment is
because of all this it's going to be
basically strongly bias towards frequent
or likely outcomes so anything that
deviates from what is seen frequently is
can implicitly have a um a statistical
bias against um outputting
so
complicated would it help to if it was
fine-tuned on prior assessments probably
yeah that's the approach I've been
trying to take is give it a rubric give
it a mass amount of data that I've got
from school medicine merge them and say
these are the results typically result
in this come on this rubric now here's a
new data set right rubrics are good
anything you can do to make it more a
internally grounded question like
grounded within the within the text that
it's looking at that'll help with
reliability any other um we can't see
the chat so I don't know if oh okay is
there are there any questions in the
chat none yet any
other yeah sort of my name
is great um I mean I I have a very sort
of basic understanding of AI at my age
it's also very difficult to kind of
comprehend sort of how it works I guess
one question I have is you know to what
degree is language actually a limiting
factor it seems like language for us
humans is you know sort of a way to put
complex thoughts in a way that can
translate to communicate somebody else
it feels like for now a lot of the input
is based on language yeah like you're
saying intility
things are shifting right we can now
diagn the program can
diagnose diabetes and incense just based
on EKG can look at things that we cannot
even perceive and at what point does one
start to worry that it might just bypass
that interaction and just move just to
much more measurable parameters in other
words if a computer can just observe a
patient sitting in emergency room for an
hour instead of trying to understand
the communication between provider and
patient kind of come up with some sort
of algorithm like I feel like that
that's the part that scares me most that
you know I mean I
guess so like clunky it's yeah it's like
coloring with four colors when fact you
have well well you know I mean it's
funny because no one really knows for
sure why these large language models
work so well no one can see can you know
um there's a guy named Steven Wolfram
who's a mathematician and um has you
know worked in machine learning for many
years and he wrote this small book you
know basically saying that we don't
really know for sure what's going on
here but something about you know giving
you know massive numbers of words so
massive amounts of language to these
models and whatever kind of training is
going on with them leads them to to
sound very um human and the question is
um um you know is is there like um is
there actual sentient intelligence there
or is it just a statistical thing that
these words are most likely to follow
these other words um you know I I don't
know that we know I and so I mean the
you know I my view you know again maybe
I'm too old but um I I don't see in my
lifetime any of these systems um
replacing positions now being
intelligent
assistants um you know I think is is
probably um um going to be a role at
some point someone walks in the
emergency department and and you have to
be careful about human design because
you don't want that automation bias that
you know the you know here's the patient
and you know doctor so and so and here's
what the computer thanks um it there
might be better ways to do that so that
you're not um
biased but because you've heard what the
computer thinks um but at some point the
computer May well be helpful because we
all know that Physicians are far from
perfect um in terms of oh you know did
you think about this or oh you know they
um um you know there's a rare disease
that has these kind of symptoms and and
things like these kind of findings and
things like that so I I think it will
ultimately come down to you know to how
they're used um you know the they I mean
clearly they work very well there's no
question about that um but the the
question is how they will be used in a
way that will benefit um patient care um
and also you know benefit the work of
Physicians because if you never having
to make decisions anymore um then your
thinking processes are going to become
Rusty but I I don't know that's just
some kind of random thoughts sure Steve
well there's a question the chat that
actually follow on that sure anybody has
so this is from
um there have been discussions about en
and Ai scribing and the role that
Learners met students residents Etc
should plan implementation any thoughts
on the act of placing thoughts on notes
for Learners versus the fact that note
writing is clearly going in this
direction I think that's yes to like and
please chime in the chat if I'm
incorrectly interpreting but it sounds
like that's ask me a little bit about
how are people going to learn properly
or AI learn from student notes that are
perhaps not ideal right yeah Yeah well
yeah well you know and I mean I think
yeah well you know the I think the the
notes thing is interesting because you
know there's another thing we've learned
from now about 15 years of using
electronic health records is that we we
have made life a lot more difficult for
um Physicians and probably other
clinicians too um in in terms of the
time it takes you know to enter notes
back in the day when I saw patients um
either we would scribble short notes on
a piece of paper or we could pick up the
phone and dictate and then some
transcriptionist somewhere would
transcribe it and then a day or two
later it would show up in our mailbox
printed on a piece of paper um and um
you know and then in the transition to
electronic health records we've made
Physicians become the um
transcribers and um that's led to a lot
of burnout and and so you know part of
the value of these automated um uh note
uh generating systems is is that they um
hopefully will make life easier um you
know require less time so Physicians
don't have to go home at night and
finish up their charting and so forth
and I know that Vanessa just uh um did
some research uh uh showing if I if I
tell me if I don't interpret it right
but that at least gp4 is not quite ready
for prime time to do that but there are
commercial products including products
that U um is implementing do you have
anything to add to that or I know a
competitor of Dax is a bridge and they
are um have implemented an Emory and
they allow medical students and
residents to use the technology and it's
interesting because their spin or what
they are saying about it is that
depending on your level of training
you're really focused on different areas
of the interview so you send a medical
student in they're going to Nail Social
history they're going to really get the
alcoholic history tobacco use they're
very good and more comfortable doing
that their differential and what their
assessment and plan is probably not as
robust but that's an area which is going
to be edited and hopefully before kind
of signing in and going iteratively into
the model would be fixed before being
trained on it um
hopefully the uh we don't know yeah um
what they also said was a benefit is
that you actually get to truly see what
was asked so as an attending you don't
have to then go back and ask the smoking
history all over again because it was
captured um and so there were there's
greater overlay and therefore the
attending by the time the medical
student and the resident have gone
through can Target the true assessment
and plan as to moving
forward yeah greton you were GNA and
even even
backing up a little bit from that what
we discovered is that having students
try to write notes early in in the first
two years they really didn't understand
what goes in what's the difference
between a review of systems and a
physical exam maybe now that's mov maybe
this whole this is going to shift the
Reliance on that age old so per app so I
don't I don't know yeah well I I mean I
remember when I was a medical student
you know like we were expected to write
these um tone hes on patients you know
pages and pages of stuff um which
probably no one should should be doing
but you know as a medical student though
you could you could impress your
attending physician by every last thing
you asked or examined and every last
possible differential diagnosis but um
that that kind of skill is not really
good for um um practicing Physicians
where things need to be a lot more
succinct um we're actually a little bit
past the time I'm happy to stick around
I know there's a fellow's I think
there's a done for the term so I don't
know everybody
have yeah so if people um if people
wanna uh want to go that's fine I I can
stick around um if if you go to my if
you want to get these slides they're on
my web page
bill.in or drop me an email or maybe
actually I'll send the link around there
um they're on our they're on the D
server so maybe someday these two will
train the next uh generation of large
language model anyways thank you all
thank
you